Générique
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous.
Très heureux de vous retrouver
pour nouveau numéro de "Parlement
hebdo", l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Aujourd'hui, nous
accueillons Prisca Thevenot.
Merci d'être avec nous.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette
semaine, une mobilisation massive
s'est organisée contre la réforme
des retraites.
Il y a eu entre 1 million et 2
millions de personnes dans la rue,
ce jeudi.
Une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation est prévue pour mardi
31 janvier.
Le Sénat a étudié le texte qui
prévoit de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires.
A l'Assemblée nationale, les
députés ont adopté à l'unanimité
la proposition de loi qui crée une
aide d'urgence pour les victimes
de violences conjugales.
- Kathia Gilder: La mobilisation
était donc au rendez-vous, ce
jeudi 19 janvier.
Plus d'un million de manifestants,
selon la police, et 2 millions,
selon la CGT.
- 85% des Français sont hostiles à
cette réforme.
Il est encore temps de reculer, et
de comprendre que, quand on
gouverne, on gouverne pas contre
son pays, mais pour lui.
- Le fait d'être dans la rue peut
peser et faire en sorte que cette
réforme soit annulée.
C'est notre objectif.
On va contribuer à ce qu'il en
soit ainsi.
- Ce n'est pas une question
d'unité de la gauche, mais une
question de colère des gens.
Ils pourront faire des petits
amendements, ça ne changera rien à
cette colère.
Nous ne voulons pas travailler
plus.
- La question est de savoir si ce
projet Macron, Elisabeth Borne et
Eric Ciotti est le bon.
La réponse est non.
Il y avait déjà un projet de
réforme porté par Edouard Philippe
et Emmanuel Macron.
On a gagné le bras de fer.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a eu entre 1
et 2 millions de personnes dans la
rue, selon les chiffres.
Vous reconnaissez la forte
mobilisation qu'il y a eu ce jeudi
contre la réforme?
Vous assumez de faire une réforme
impopulaire?
- Prisca Thevenot: Est-ce qu'il y
a eu une mobilisation ce jeudi,
oui.
Il faut rappeler que cette
mobilisation a pour enjeu une
expression légitime de
revendications.
Si ces revendications se sont
exprimées ce jeudi, elles ont pu
être entendues à d'autres moments.
Les voix se sont aussi entendues
pendant les élections
présidentielles, législatives, et
pendant les concertations et
consultations menées par le
gouvernement.
Elles vont se poursuivre.
Elles vont se poursuivre à
l'Assemblée nationale, en
commission, et ensuite, dans
l'hémicycle.
Ces voix, pour s'exprimer, il faut
qu'aucune ne soit oubliée.
Il faut tout entendre.
Au-delà de la colère, il faut
entendre les demandes.
Elles sont légitimes.
Elles peuvent aussi être du
ressort de l'angoisse, de la peur.
On parle de quelque chose
d'important, du moment de notre
retraite.
Attention à ne pas tout résumer en
un bruit de certains politiques.
Il faut écouter les Français.
Il ne faut pas transformer ce
débat de société en un débat
simplement entre politiques.
- Alexandre Poussart: Beaucoup de
Français ont manifesté et beaucoup
ont fait grève.
La grève va se poursuivre à partir
de lundi, dans certains secteurs.
Vous craignez un blocage du pays?
- Prisca Thevenot: Non, je crains
un blocage du débat.
Derrière ces manifestations, il
faut aussi entendre la demande et
l'expression plus générale, qui va
même au-delà de la réforme des
retraites.
On peut entendre des
revendications sur des points que
l'on peut écouter.
Il y a la question de l'équité.
Nous devons y répondre de façon
légitime et claire.
Il y a aussi le sujet du rapport
au travail, qui a changé.
Réussir sa vie, c'est réussir sa
carrière, c'est très bien.
Dans le cadre actuel de ces
manifestations, il faut revenir au
rapport sur le dialogue social.
Il doit pouvoir se réinventer.
On a l'impression que ce dialogue
social a eu lieu que dans le cadre
de manifestations.
C'est faux.
Il y a eu différentes
concertations et consultations.
Il y a aussi de nouvelles
instances.
- Kathia Gilder: Si jamais le
mouvement s'amplifie, s'accentue,
et que vous siégez dans
l'hémicycle pour étudier le projet
de réforme des retraites, vous
seriez prêts à discuter avec les
autres forces d'opposition?
Vous pourriez prendre des
amendements venus de la gauche,
par exemple?
- Prisca Thevenot: Le dialogue est
déjà présent.
Est-ce que nous sommes prêts à
prendre en compte l'ensemble des
demandes et des ambitions des
Français pour le moment de leur
retraite?
Oui.
C'est justement la raison même de
la volonté de faire cette réforme.
Ce que j'entends beaucoup, et
qu'on oublie peut-être, c'est ce
que nous voulons continuer à être
une nation solidaire.
Nous voulons continuer à être
cette nation qui fait attention à
ses aînés, qui prend soin de
celles et ceux qui ont participé à
l'effort de construction, souvent
de reconstruction de notre pays.
Nous devons pouvoir mettre tout en
oeuvre, en tant que politiques, ce
qui est notre responsabilité...
Au-delà des amendements, l'enjeu
est d'avoir tous les sujets sur la
table.
On verra si ça fait l'objet
d'amendements ou pas.
- Alexandre Poussart: Au sein de
la majorité présidentielle, vous
avez le MoDem, qui est favorable à
une hausse des cotisations
patronales.
Vous avez certains députés
Renaissance qui disent qu'ils ne
vont pas voter le texte.
Est-ce que la majorité
présidentielle peut craquer?
- Prisca Thevenot: Elle reste unie
et soudée sur le principe que nous
devons maintenir notre système de
retraites, qui est un système par
répartition.
Nous y tenons extrêmement fort.
Je le dis d'autant plus, à titre
personnel, que je suis issue de la
gauche.
Je ne me vois pas détricoter ce
système.
Ces revendications sont tout à
fait légitimes.
Il y en a d'autres, sur d'autres
bancs.
Nous devons pouvoir les étudier et
les traiter au sein des instances
démocratiques.
Ca dépend quel modèle on veut.
Il ne s'agit pas simplement de
lancer des totems et d'opposer des
tabous.
Il s'agit d'écrire la société que
nous voulons.
Nous voulons une société où chacun
peut trouver un travail juste, un
travail rémunéré, qui lui
permettra d'aller en retraite dans
des conditions physiques
correctes.
Pour que l'on puisse continuer à
être un pays qui fait de l'emploi,
qui crée du travail, nous devons
accepter aussi que nous devons ne
pas continuer à imposer de façon
forte les entreprises.
Elles participent déjà au
financement de notre retraite.
C'est faux de dire qu'elles n'y
participent pas.
- Kathia Gilder: Cette réforme, ce
n'est pas une réforme financière
pour réduire le déficit public.
C'est aussi une réforme sociale,
c'est ce que vous dites.
- Prisca Thevenot: C'est une
réforme d'équilibre.
D'équilibre budgétaire, dans le
financement même de ce système,
mais aussi d'équilibre social.
Il est complètement faux et
mensonger de dire que le système
actuel est une panacée.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Les carrières féminines ne sont
pas assez prises en compte.
Je le dis aussi en tant que fille
d'ouvriers, les carrières pénibles
ne sont pas assez prises en
compte.
Je parle des carrières hachées,
celles des proches aidants,
par exemple.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
du nucléaire.
Le Sénat a étudié un texte, cette
semaine.
Il prévoit l'accélération de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires.
Des modifications ont été
apportées au texte.
- Au départ, c'est un texte
technique qui arrive au Sénat.
Il vient fixer et simplifier les
procédures: permis de construire,
autorisations environnementales,
nécessaires pour entamer le plus
rapidement possible les projets
des futurs réacteurs EPR 2.
- Il va permettre d'accélérer les
conditions administratives.
Il aura deux objectifs: raccourcir
les délais de plusieurs années et
contribuer à en baisser le coût
pour les consommateurs.
- C'est sans compter sur les
sénateurs.
- On ne peut pas débattre
sérieusement sur la question
nucléaire sans en avoir défini une
stratégie.
Quel mix énergétique? Etc.
Après, on aura des débats et
peut-être des désaccords.
- La majorité sénatoriale a choisi
d'intégrer l'article 1, dédié à la
relance du nucléaire.
Il fait sauter deux points
majeurs.
- Nous n'allons pas préempter le
débat public.
Les 50% deviendront peut-être 75%.
Ils deviendront peut-être 20%.
Nous ne préemptons pas.
Nous disons simplement que les 50%
sont obsolètes.
- Du côté du ministère de la
Transition écologique, on estime
que c'est un mauvais coup
politique.
- Alexandre Poussart: On a vu dans
le débat qu'il y avait des petites
discordances entre le gouvernement
et les sénateurs sur le
calendrier.
Quand la droite du Sénat a diminué
la part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique, c'est en accord avec
Emmanuel Macron?
- Prisca Thevenot: Il faut
rappeler l'objectif de ce texte.
On doit avoir une position claire.
Ce n'est pas une loi de
programmation énergétique.
C'est un texte de facilitation
administrative.
La loi de programmation arrivera
en son temps.
Il faut faire les choses étape par
étape.
Il ne faut pas confondre vitesse
et précipitation.
Il ne faut pas se tromper
d'objectif.
Oui, nous voulons être sur un mix
énergétique entre énergies
renouvelables et nucléaire, mais
il n'est pas une finalité, c'est
une modalité.
C'est pour être une nation
souveraine, indépendante, dans une
ligne de décarbonation assumée
par Emmanuel Macron.
- Kathia Gilder: Le temps de
construction est très long.
Dans ce contexte, l'énergie
nucléaire est-elle toujours un
secteur d'avenir?
- Prisca Thevenot: La filière du
nucléaire est une filière
d'excellence française.
Nous devons en être fiers.
Est-ce qu'il est vrai que pendant
longtemps nous avons pas assez
fait la promotion de cette
filière, notamment en termes de
formation?
Oui.
Nous avons manqué de renouveau
pour venir combler cette filière.
C'est un fait.
Nous prenons acte de cela et nous
allons avancer dans cette
démarche.
Nous devons rappeler que ce sont
des filières sur lesquelles nous
devons continuer à mettre des
jeunes en apprentissage et en
formation pour les orienter vers
ces métiers.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
de droite du Sénat a fait voter un
amendement qui fait tripler la
peine de prison pour les
activistes écologistes qui
s'installent dans les centrales.
- Prisca Thevenot: Plus que
jamais, nous devons être fermes
avec celles et ceux qui nous
expliquent que la loi, c'est bien
pour les autres, mais pas pour
eux-mêmes.
Nous sommes dans un pays
démocratique, où nous pouvons
exprimer des oppositions et des
revendications.
Mais ça doit être dans le cadre de
la loi.
Tout ce qui viendra réprimander et
punir celles et ceux qui ne
respectent pas cette loi va dans
le bon sens.
Nous devons voir l'entièreté du
texte.
Oui, il y a certains sujets sur
lesquels nous avons une position
très ferme, mais il faut voir si
c'est dans une bonne harmonie.
Nous allons étudier toutes ces
dispositions à l'Assemblée
nationale, avec mes collègues.
- Kathia Gilder: On va passer à la
question des violences conjugales.
Elle était à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale.
Les députés ont voté une
proposition de loi qui crée une
aide universelle pour les victimes
de violences conjugales.
C'est un fait rare, elle a été
votée à l'unanimité.
- Le scrutin est clos.
- Pas une seule voix n'aura
manqué.
A l'unanimité, les députés se sont
prononcés en faveur d'une aide
financière universelle d'urgence
pour les victimes de violences
conjugales.
Une aide sous la forme d'un prêt à
taux 0 ou d'un don versé par la
CAF en fonction de la situation de
la victime.
- Si vous rajoutez à cela des
difficultés financières, cela
devient encore plus compliqué de
partir.
Les allers et retours peuvent se
multiplier.
C'est pourquoi ce texte est
important.
- Le barème de l'aide doit encore
être précisé par décret.
Cette aide sera conditionnée au
dépôt d'une plainte dans un
commissariat ou dans une
gendarmerie, notamment.
La gauche voulait aller plus loin.
- On voulait envoyer un signal à
ces 7% de femmes.
Celles qui posent une main
courante.
C'est un geste fort qui sera fait.
- 122 femmes ont été tuées par
leur conjoint ou ex-conjoint, en
2022.
- Kathia Gilder: On a l'impression
que cela a été très long à être
mis en place et reconnu.
- Prisca Thevenot: C'est fait.
C'est fait de façon
transpartisane.
On a tendance à considérer que
l'Assemblée nationale, c'est
surtout des bruits et des débats
qui sont vains.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Nous avons pu voir que quand il
s'agissait du droit des femmes,
nous ne parlions que d'une seule
voix.
Nous étions là pour enrichir le
texte.
J'ai énormément travaillé avec
Sandrine Rousseau, notamment.
Ce travail ne s'est pas porté sur
les discordes politiciennes, mais
sur nos ambitions.
Ce n'est pas souvent retranscrit
médiatiquement.
On en parle très peu.
C'est une avancée importante pour
les victimes de violences
conjugales.
Souvent, la violence économique
s'ajoute à la violence des coups.
La victime ne peut pas subvenir à
ses propres besoins, souvent.
Là, nous mettons en place un
dispositif sous la forme d'un prêt
ou d'un don.
- Alexandre Poussart: Depuis des
années, il y a beaucoup de mesures
pour lutter contre les violences
conjugales, mais on voit que les
féminicides se multiplient, dans
notre pays.
Le législateur n'est-il pas
impuissant?
- Prisca Thevenot: Nous devons
continuer à parler de ces sujets.
Nous devons continuer à assumer
nos responsabilités, politiques et
citoyennes.
Il y a un travail fondamental fait
par de nombreuses personnes dans
les centres spécialisés, mais
également par les associations sur
le terrain.
Nous devons continuer à ne pas
lâcher.
- Kathia Gilder: Un député a été
condamné pour violences
conjugales.
Il s'appelle Adrien Quatennens.
Il a fait son retour, la semaine
dernière, en commission, mais pas
encore en séance publique.
Vous allez aussi vous opposer à ce
qu'il vienne dans l'hémicycle?
- Prisca Thevenot: J'aimerais
rappeler que je suis en commission
des Affaires sociales.
C'était là que devait siéger
Adrien Quatennens.
J'ai entendu dans les médias qu'il
faisait son retour.
On a été quelques-uns à se
demander où il était.
Il n'était pas là.
On a beaucoup parlé de ce retour.
Pour moi, ça reste quelque chose
d'hypothétique, puisque je ne l'ai
pas revu.
- Kathia Gilder: Il est à la
commission des Affaires
étrangères.
- Prisca Thevenot: Je ne l'ai pas
vu dans l'hémicycle, et je ne l'ai
pas croisé dans les couloirs.
Ma question est la suivante...
Que va-t-il dire?
Que va-t-il faire?
Va-t-il pouvoir prendre la parole?
Va-t-il pouvoir légiférer?
Qu'aurait-il dit sur la
proposition de loi sur les aides
pour les victimes de violences
conjugales?
Nous avons cette responsabilité de
la parole politique, qui est bien
mise à mal, aujourd'hui.
J'estime qu'il a aussi cette
responsabilité de la parole
politique, qu'il a pour lui-même,
mais aussi pour nous tous.
Il doit se demander quels enjeux,
quels textes et quels discours il
sera en légitimité de pouvoir
porter?
S'il dit qu'il peut le faire,
qu'il revienne, et que l'on
constate nous-mêmes.
S'il n'est pas en capacité, il
peut retourner devant les urnes et
redemander la confiance de ses
électeurs.
- Alexandre Poussart: La semaine
dernière, un collégien s'est donné
la mort, car il subissait du
harcèlement à cause de son
homosexualité.
- Il avait seulement 13 ans.
Il avait toute une vie devant lui.
Pourtant, le 7 janvier dernier,
Lucas s'est donné la mort.
Pourquoi, en 2023, en France, un
gamin homosexuel en arrive-t-il à
se suicider?
Parce que, et croyez-moi, je sais
trop bien de quoi je parle, il
arrive qu'à envisager qu'une vie
de moquerie, de rejet, d'exclusion
et de haine, on n'arrive plus à
envisager de vie du tout.
- Quand un enfant met fin à ses
jours, on n'a plus de mots, pour
exprimer le chagrin, la douleur...
Il n'y a pas de mots.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise?
J'adresse mes pensées les plus
émues à ses parents, à ses
proches, à ses amis.
Ce drame montre à quel point la
lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire, la lutte contre
l'homophobie, parce que
l'homophobie tue, oui, doit
demeurer une priorité du
gouvernement.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette image
d'un ministre en larmes après ce
drame, ça peut favoriser la prise
de conscience?
- Prisca Thevenot: Les larmes du
ministre de l'Education nationale
retranscrivent l'émotion d'une
nation entière.
Ce que j'aimerais rappeler, c'est
que nous devons continuer à avoir
des mots très fermes.
C'est non!
Ca suffit!
On ne peut pas subir du
harcèlement en raison de sa
couleur de peau, de son
orientation sexuelle, ou je ne
sais quoi encore.
Oui, l'homophobie tue encore en
France, de façon violente, et de
façon plus jeune.
Nous devons tous nous lever sur ce
sujet-là, le dénoncer, et surtout,
ne plus se taire.
Nous devons être unis et soudés.
Il faut continuer à l'être et à ne
plus nous taire.
Nous devons continuer à expliquer
que nos enfants doivent vivre
librement.
Je rappellerais quelque chose
d'important: aimer, c'est
formidable.
Pourquoi certains seraient
capables de nous dire que nous
n'avons pas le droit d'aimer ceux
que nous aimons?
Il faut montrer le chemin à nos
enfants.
- Kathia Gilder: Certains
ministres actuels s'étaient
opposés au mariage pour tous.
Est-ce que ces prises de position
ont pu participer au climat
d'homophobie?
Est-ce que c'est encore
admissible?
- Prisca Thevenot: Nous devons
avoir une parole ferme et forte.
Je le redis, je l'assume et je le
revendique.
Nous devons être capables
d'admettre que des personnes
évoluent.
Nous faisons de la politique pour
que les mentalités évoluent.
- Kathia Gilder: Ils ont évolué,
pour vous?
- Prisca Thevenot: On ne peut pas
reprocher à quelqu'un qui a eu...
Attention, ils n'ont pas eu des
propos homophobes.
Ils ont été contre, effectivement,
le mariage pour tous.
Je suis pour le mariage pour tous,
soyons très clairs.
Ils sont revenus sur leurs
positions, tant mieux.
A nous de veiller à ce que ce
chemin fait soit un chemin sincère
et, surtout, sans retour possible.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va
regarder ce qu'il y aura à
l'agenda du Parlement la semaine
prochaine.
- Kathia Gilder: Lundi,
l'atterrissage à l'Assemblée
nationale de la réforme des
retraites.
Olivier Dussopt sera auditionné
après la présentation du texte en
Conseil des ministres.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mercredi,
les sénateurs vont interroger
Pierre Moscovici.
Il va donner son avis sur cette
réforme des retraites.
Mardi, au Sénat, les sénateurs
vont commencer à débattre sur le
projet de loi des Jeux Olympiques
2024, avec notamment des mesures
sur la sécurité de l'événement.
Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA